no I think it's basically fundamental in
terms of when much is given much is
expected to be given back and returned
and there's so much people can consume
in terms of wealth and require in terms
of wealth if one has been blessed or
been fortunate enough to have got much
more than normal wealth it is but
natural that one expects a certain
finish tree responsibility in terms of
how that wealth is applied used and
leveraged for purposes of society
you know I think the the concept of the
strong linkage to the family is breaking
down in Western nations to the
obligations which I think to the clinics
are not only Indian but a people feel
towards their families is much less in
terms of Western people and particularly
American people so when you take a
philosophy approach that you do not have
to leave well to your families you then
have to tell yourself do you take it to
the grave or do you donate it for some
more worthwhile purpose and this also
reflects in the way that families get
structured you know children live
separately children put old parents into
homes instead of putting them into their
homes for the children expect from the
parents and what the parents expect from
the children
we've been focusing on primary education
in India for the past nine years both in
Wipro limited as well as in the
foundation we set up or I set up Youssef
you had to make a bet where you think
you could really make a contribution but
you could really build a depth
understanding so we were very clear from
the day one that we had to have a focus
to is it had to be a cause which was
relevant to the country in terms of need
a critical cause in terms of need where
you saw a gap between what could be and
what is and three it should be an area
where it should have an access beyond
just a specific educating of a child we
concluded that if we could educate
children better in our country you would
have better citizens but importantly we
also realized that if you educate the
girls child when she grows up and starts
a family she has a smaller family which
is a ryujin in terms of the growth of
our population which is more manageable
and three again if you educate the girl
child when she grows up and she starts a
family or looks after a household she
has much higher consciousness on primary
health care
I think you know what you must
understand is the state of education in
India you have one side the cities which
have very good schools every schools and
not-so-good school the level of
education in these cities is fairly good
they get fairly good teachers on the
other side you have the villages of
India where 65 to 70% of the people of
India live and there we have education
which is in the villages and 90% of that
education is run by the state
governments a partly funded by the
central government where the state
government does not charge any fees
gives free uniforms gives a free mid-day
meal which is very often the best meal
the child gets and where there are 6
million unionized teachers in the States
government multiple state governments
which we have across the country
standards of education they are very
very low the commitment of the teachers
is very very low the quality of the
teacher the training of the teachers is
very very low so there's an enormous
amount one can do to upgrade the quality
of teaching the quality of the teachers
the way the curricula is actually
learned the way it is facilitated to be
learnt the way you can community
intervene to get community breakers
building up on the education system to
demand certain standards the way you can
train the teacher training institute
there are 600 districts in India every
district in India has a teacher training
institute and every teacher in the state
government school requires to spend 15
days of retraining in these Institute's
most of these institutes are in shambles
and many of them have teachers who are
worse than the teachers they're supposed
to teach so this enormous amount of
leverage one can do in terms of
upgrading this entire infrastructure or
which the government spends a lot of
money there's an enormous amount one can
do in training and upgrading the quality
of the state functionaries that's
precisely what we do in our Foundation
and we have been successful now because
we have been working for nine years in
this and we involved now with over two
and a half million children
I think the most important thing is we
have to maintain fiscal discipline
whether it be in our fiscal deficits
whether it be in terms of focusing in
terms of development in areas which can
generate scarce resources and therefore
back inflation rates and in terms of
integrity in a leadership
oh that's completely irrelevant frankly
one wouldn't even think of it it's a
mature democracy of 1.1 1 billion people
we've had a tradition of successful
democracy since 46:47 we applauded were
the only governments democratic
governments in the world which were more
than 10 years has successfully led and
managed coalition governments Alliance
governments Britain is facing it now and
they're panicked but as we have done it
successfully for 10 years three
governments and done it and the job has
got done the job of nation-building the
job of nation leadership in a difficult
complex coalition government has worked
what more majority can you expect from a
democracy
it will make sense because the companies
are going up the value chain and as the
international companies are trying to
learn our business models we are
learning their business model properly
faster than they're learning our
business model so cost arbitrage will
always be there because the cost
arbitrage is not determined by two
million engineers in the country who are
working on a job or three million
engineers in a country of work on a job
the cost arbitrage is determined by the
standard of living of over a billion
people which is still much much lower
than the rest of the developed world
much much low and when the developed
world escalates even at 3% on salary
levels a year they escalate on a base of
a hundred whereas even if you escalate
at 7% a year on a salary there will not
10% a year on a salary level we escalate
not on a base of a hundred but we
escalate on a base of somewhere between
10 and 20 they just run mathematics and
you will find that even at high
inflation rates the gap continues to be
there if not increase
I think the Chinese government is
realizing that the economy is
overheating so I think they will take
proactive steps to slow down the last
quarter understand the growths are
running at rates of 12% of your GDP and
twos I think the Chinese government is
seriously considering whether they
should firm the Chinese currency because
of international pressure but also
because the economy is heating up too
much in terms of flows through exports
one is very obviously which
economists will tell you it's got to fix
its problem of the fiscal deficit it's
getting out of control
dues I think the American consumer must
learn to live within his or her means
you cannot have a society where you
spend more than you earn I mean it's
just fundamentally not viable in the
long run I think the corrective steps
which are taking place now should lead
in the right direction I think one is
that the India the American consumer is
learning to save why the saving which
you are running negative now are running
between four and five percent and so far
the fiscal deficit is concerned I think
the president and his team are
addressing issues which are economic to
see to it that they come under more
contain fiscal deficit and the president
is making tough decisions which is why
he is getting unpopular with some of the
commercial leadership
I was supreme optimist my big concern is
that the this period of of reset of the
world too much protectionism is building
up among the developed world and that
protectionism is very dangerous and that
protection is also building up among
services which is the next emerging flow
of trade because 60% of the world
services 40% of the worldís products and
agriculture or industry and agriculture
if if the developed world starts putting
restrictions on flow services the
developing world which has power of
economics and power of consumption
markets will put restrictions on flow of
products and that's very simple to be
but all you have to do Israelis import
tariffs which have fallen on a
systematic basis over the past 10 15
years so you trigger a war of less trade
I think that would be the most
regressive thing when the developed
world could be doing